today we're fortunate to have a highly
skilled player boneless here to share
with us the top 10 strategy secrets to
improve your terraforming Mars game now
we'll look at all the essentials
including card synergies timing your
play how to leverage your engine and the
best paths to generate high scores and
date your opponents this is legendary
tactics
[Music]
terraforming Mars is the number six game
on Board Game Geek right now and is
consistently ranked as one of the best
10 board games since its release in
2016. last year we met a talented Danish
gamer and he's back to teach us
terraforming Mars welcome boneless
hello thanks for having me oh no problem
well I could tell you're a man of skill
when I spoke to you about wingspan last
year so I'm excited to see what uh
strategies you offer us this year and uh
before we start our 10 strategy tips
though I want to ask you why is it that
you enjoy this game so much it's uh my
own personal favorite game I think it's
so so deep it's like engine building but
like the best kind of engine building
you can like go in and in like 10
different directions and you have a new
game every time and it's very satisfying
oh that's perfect well we'll get into
that in detail very soon so let's start
with our number one to begin I think we
absolutely have to talk about player
count because in my mind the strategies
of the game depend on how many players
are at the table so can you offer the
major differences that we should
consider depending on how many players
are playing
yeah basically the game the way the way
the game works is that the the three
parameters has to be satisfied so it
doesn't even matter how many players you
are the three parameters still have to
be satisfied so if you are in a five
player games it tend to be shorter in
terms of generations because now there
are five players eager to terraform
as opposed to like a two-player game
then the game is gonna go a lot longer
in terms of of generations because now
they're only two players to terraform
everything all three air parameters
right this matters a lot actually
because it means that in five player
games you cannot get away with so much
greed you have to like really get your
points pretty fast because you just have
fewer turns but in two player games it's
uh it's much easier to just go for the
big greedy engine and a lot of card draw
and make a ton of points this way right
so there's sort of two different
approaches the short push or the rush
versus the longer game and so in a
higher player count you're going to want
to go with the shorter play style
correct
yeah as a rule yeah definitely
let's say the terraforming strategy
let's call it this it's a it's much
better in four or five player games so
what you do is instead of like getting a
lot of a big greedy engine instead of
getting a lot of Mega credit production
you still have to get a little bit but
then what you do is you get a lot of
playing production heat production you
just go for straight Tiara like a lot of
asteroids and stuff like this and you
just try to get as many points as soon
as you can because the game is not going
to be that long
very nice let's move to our number two
now at the start of the game you get
some choice about which Corporation to
take in your mind which ones have the
best abilities and do you have success
with any particular corporation
um there's a lot of different
corporations I think
a lot of them are strong but basically
what I'm looking for initially is just
what can give me the best
the best amount of cards and mega
credits and steel and titanium right
here right now and then can they effect
be beneficial to me towards the game and
then we also back to like Play account
because for example this Omni
Corporation it's it's one of the worst
corporations in the game it's the one
where you get if you made a tier of this
generation you can get one more TR for
three Mega credits like this Corporation
for example is only good in four or five
player games and even then it's
questionable but it's just completely
unplayable in two-player games because
it just it does so little for you so uh
but it sounds like it'll bleed your
credits down too yeah
but the of course
some corporations are stronger than
others like
there's a lot of good ones like if
you're going for greedy game like veto
or Point Luna or manutech or something
like this and even in shorter games
these corporations are also solid
and then in five player games I I could
tend a little bit more like I think
thuses or maybe Omni but even Omni is
not that good there so I mean all you
have to do is just look at your two
corporations look at your starting hand
and also have the Play account in mind
just figure out what is best for you in
this game
that's great thank you very much well
let's move to our third point and this
is I want to focus on the early game
here and with most engine builders it's
important to get your economy up and
running quickly so what thoughts do you
have on how you should spend your
credits in the early game and when a
player needs to focus on income
generation
well income Generation
Um if it's a long game and and you'd
only really know if it's gonna be a long
game it can like shape out in a lot of
different ways but generally speaking if
it's a two or three player game you know
it's gonna be fairly long in terms of
generation so in this case the best
approach by far is just to get some card
draws and make a credit production some
field production some titanium
production also TR to a lesser extent
but mostly you're just looking for stuff
you can build a lot of cars with and
then you look for a lot of card draw and
if you can get these two things running
you can you can generate a lot of points
in two play games is it effective to
balance your approach to this or do you
tend to want to focus on one or the
other of these resources
um I think Mega critics is probably the
strongest especially in these uh in
these longer games even in four or five
player games I would still take the mega
credit I can get in the early game like
if you start with the Quiet companies
even in a five player game I'll still
play that but the the difference is in
the five player game you also heavily
relying on like straight TR or heat
production plan production something
like this I mean in in two or three
player games it's all about the the
greedy card strategy you just have to
get a bunch of cards a bunch of income
and uh then you go for the long game so
how do you decide specifically which
cards to take in those early rounds and
how many cards to take is that based on
their cost more or is it based on the
value that they add to your game or to
your engine for me I look at all the
options I have and I wonder should I
save my money or should I be spending it
what's your advice there well first of
all you should be spending your mega
credits it's a it's a generally it's
pretty bad to just pass the generation
with 20 Mega credits if you're doing
this it's only because you have like an
expensive card like iron mining
Industries or some some other really
expensive car that you want to play the
following generation so basically you
want to invest your
your cards as soon as possible yeah all
right so I'd like to ask you about those
starting cards in the starting hand what
would you say is the ideal cost for
cards that you're picking up early on
when you don't have much of an engine
built
um basically you want the cards that can
pay for themselves in the shortest
amount of generations like
a card like immigration shuttles this
takes a little more than I believe six
generations to pay for itself it costs
30 plus three for the card and it gives
you like five Mega credit production so
it could be tempting to look at this
card but but this is almost too
expensive but you're really searching
for is like
uh I guess acquired companies or some of
these uh a bit cheaper like a credit
production
um cards nice but yeah as a general rule
you want cards that can pay for
themselves in five or fewer Generations
um
otherwise it's not really worth it but
basically you just have to play the best
cards that are available available so
you have to play with the cards you get
obviously
that's great okay well let's move on to
our fourth strategy tip and part of the
beauty of a game like terraforming Mars
is reading the options presented to you
and choosing the best pathway so I'd
like to ask you what are the main
options or synergies that a player can
focus on when they're deciding which
project cards to pursue or perhaps I
should ask what are the primary and best
paths to victory in this game this is a
huge question I know I'm sorry for such
a big one
no I mean you're completely right
synergies is like a big part of it so
the biggest type of synergies in this
game is pretty much like cop discount so
if you have some cop discount of a
different variety obviously you you are
trying to guide your game in that
direction but it's also like when you
get your corporation if your corporation
is like Poseidon then you're more
inclined to go for colonies if you're a
corporation is classes you're more
inclined to go for cities there's a lot
of City Synergy in this game so if you
get a few of these combo pieces let that
like boost your cities immigrant City or
Martian rails or something like this
then of course you maybe just go over
cities this game
um so so Synergy is like a huge part of
it there's a lot of different synergies
but but mainly in the early game in the
opening hand I think the Synergy that
that I look for first of all is like
what can give me the most to make a
credit and card draw can I can I go for
this card strategy so to speak others
although synergies could be like a talk
about the city Synergy is a big one it
would also be something simple like do I
have some a little bit of heat Synergy
heat production is is way better if you
have like just a little bit of of stuff
that can um
um like some of these discount cards are
really good with the heat production for
example but it could also just be the
case that you have boost for heat
there's also this card that can turn
five feet into three steel or something
like this right away so yeah Heats
energy serious energy and it it could be
a variety of other things that well to
me that's what makes a really good game
is that you can't just pick one strategy
that's why I love Puerto Rico because
there's lots of different ways to win
and that's why I don't love Agricola
because it's it's a very balanced you
you can't just focus so that's very cool
well moving on to our number five one
part of the game that I love is that the
game gives you a goal and it just offers
you a huge tool kit with which you can
reach the goal and it lets you figure
out how to get there so at what point
should you start thinking about other
tools in your kit like milestones and
awards is this an early mid or late game
Focus
um Milestones is uh I hate to keep
beating this horse but it really depends
the number of players like Milestone and
five player games is like an actual race
you just have to get the Milestone as
soon as possible and then it's like
gradually changing like four player is
also pretty important three players then
I'm not really uh I mean you should also
you should always have milestones in
mind you should always try to get one of
them and when you look at the starting
hand this is also one of the things you
should be planning ahead slightly but
it's not like a race to get all the
Milestone as soon as possible because
then you're just completely destroying
your own game it has to be one of the
Milestones it's like come naturally to
you right in two player games it's uh
it's it's really not that important like
it could even be generation six or seven
or something before you even consider
milestones in a two-player game but that
being said they are of course they are
of course really nice it's getting five
victory points for only eight even
though you have to get it this early
it's still very efficient
but just just don't buy three standard
project cities just so you can get the
major Milestone it's really not worth it
you have to take the Milestones that are
naturally on your path gotcha okay yeah
that is reminiscent of wingspan it's
those end of round bonuses right exactly
yeah yeah that's very cool Awards you
also asked about Awards yeah those are
late game push through I think the three
Milestones are usually to be taken first
you can also start the first award if
you're right really confident that
you're gonna win it but you really have
to be confident if if there's at least
like if you're not sure you're gonna win
it it's actually not worth it to start
it so early but the first one of course
it's only eight so you you could argue
that one could be played in the early to
mid game but the one that costs 14 and
the one costs 20. this is mid to late
game uh I would even sometimes I wait
until the last generation before I even
think about getting the one that costs
20.
um because the thing is it's 20 make a
credit and then you get Five Points
that's kind of good but the math doesn't
really stop here because then you're
also feeding a second place to your
opponent and most importantly it could
also be the case that someone just
surprises you with a card or something
and then you yeah then you are not even
getting first place in that award so you
really have to be careful with these
Awards they can they can lose you the
game if you've spent 14 and 20 and then
your opponent like stealing these two
Awards away from you then you lost the
game oh shoot okay well let's move on to
number six this is opponents and timing
I want to talk about here uh this isn't
really a game in my opinion where you
can just put your head down and focus on
your own board so I wonder to what
degree do you pay close attention to
what your opponents are doing and then
change the timing of your play based on
what they're doing
yeah
um this is of course really important
the The General
idea of this game is that if you are
having the greedy the best engine if
you're having like the best game you got
a lot of Mega credit a lot of uh card
draw then it's in your if you are the
big horse if you if you're the guy who
got all the stuff then it's your
opponents really should be closing the
game sooner uh because then like if
you're going for the terraforming
strategy you're gonna make a lot of
points in the early game the mid game in
the late game if you're going for the
big greedy engine then you're getting
nothing in the early to mid game then
you're only making point in the late
game so this is what's really important
for like the terraforming strategy to
like close the game as soon as possible
to to Really punish the greedy guy
because in the late game you cannot you
cannot win against the guy who got all
the cards and all the engine so your
only option is to to close the game at
this point right okay are there any
other counter strategies specific
strategies you could offer so for
example if a player is placing Greenery
tiles what can you do to disrupt that
and I should ask you to is turn order
important in terms of who's going when
yeah let's take the first one first
um if if you're talking greeneries
you're probably also talking cities
um because I think these two things are
really linked so in order to disrupt the
city guy you could do a few different
things first of all the easiest thing
you can do is just play cities in a
daily cards yourself like if you're
against passes and he's building a lot
of cities just play pets just play
Immigrant City because this way he can
still play cities if he wants but but
when he does he's also going to feed you
make a credit and and victory points if
you play pets so that's the easiest way
to counter it the other thing you can do
is just play exactly like one or two
cities during the game and preferably
like in the middle of this Empire
um it also depends how many plant
production you have yourself but you
don't really have to have more than one
or two cities if you're playing against
us it's fine as long as you put it in
the middle of his Empire somewhere uh to
be really annoying and then he's kind of
got in that case he has to like give you
Mega credit or give you free VP because
you're playing next to his uh
his greeneries and and even if it's if
it's in the middle of his Empire sooner
or later he will have to have greeneries
because it's also going to like touch
his own cities and then you're gonna get
some some victory points for free right
there's a good thing you can do to
counter fast this is all of these
special times and it's the same idea as
just placing a city in the middle of the
Empire you could just like achieve a lot
of those special tiles and just be a
little terrorist and just be really you
know that's awesome and what about turn
order yeah do you pay attention to that
much yes turn order is actually really
important it's it's important when it
comes to bonuses it's important when it
comes to a lot of different things
um so if I know that I'm gonna start the
next generation and I also in this
generation maybe because I I only took
one action on my turn or something then
I'll have a lot of actions in a row and
that can actually be really impactful
um for example you can use this if you
get like four or five actions in a row
you can you can use it to to just claim
a bonus or set yourself up to claim like
both the bonus on the oxygen scale and
maybe also the water it's really funny
when this happens it's like it's really
game changing if you can get set
yourself up to get both of these bonuses
for example it's also like if you know
that you're gonna start the next
Generation you can really plan all right
can can I just be greedy and wait until
the start of the Next Generation before
I actually buy the Milestone or the
award I want because if if you learn to
take into account the player order then
you can use this to to to actually
maximize your efficiency so instead of
just all right I I have three cities now
no claiming mayor you could just wait
until the next generation for example
that makes sense that's awesome so for
our seventh strategy I'd like to move to
the mid game and this is after you've
got your foundational engine you've got
your trajectory in the game figured out
and since the game ends when Mars is
terraformed it's important that players
pay attention to how slowly or quickly
this is happening so what ideas would
you offer on one knowing when you want
to move the game more quickly by
advancing those tracks and two how to
slow down or speed up the game
yeah in terms of speeding up the game
then we're back to the thing we talked
about before like if the opponent is is
the greedy guy with the bigger that
that's often me actually yeah so if I
have the big engine that'd be a lot of
card draw then my opponents should
should do what they can to close the
game and once again this is like a lot
more plausible in four or five player
games in two player games I mean my one
opponent and two player he can terraform
as much as he wants he's still not gonna
close the game that soon in a two-player
game so so it's definitely more a thing
in four or five player games but that
being said like if we're getting like
the generation seven or something and
and even in a two-play game if you can
see that your opponent all right he
still has 20 cards I have two cards then
of course it is still in your best
interest to to try to to close the game
to especially if you feel like you're
hit right now but later on you're
definitely gonna gonna struggle then of
course you wanna close the game that's
great and what was the second part of
your question uh the second part was how
you slow down or speed up the game are
there do you have any clever ways to do
that Beyond just the you know advancing
the track more quickly or yeah in two
three player games you can actually
artificially make the game longer this
this is like one of the really annoying
little strategies you can do but what
you can do is you can just you can just
not spend your heat like you you try to
like identify the last parameter that is
if needed to close the game and then
there's never terrify that right yeah
you're not helping with with the
terrifying uh because in this case it's
uh yeah so so if you have protected
habitat what I've done a few times is
that I just keep all my plans I just
don't don't use my plans for a long time
and then I make sure that the game goes
to like
11 12 or 13 or even 14 sometimes you can
also do it with heat
yeah like just and and the little side
bonus is that for example with heat you
can just if you do if you did this and
then you you can see all right now the
heat is kind of close to to being closed
then you can use all of the heat you
have maybe in the in and yeah you can
use a lot of the heat you have to to
claim the the bonus because you just
stacked up so much of it so it's also a
way to get like the water bonus on the
on the heat scale
and also if the parameters close to
closing of course you want to be using
all of the the heat to get the last few
available here but the sometimes it
matters more that you are efficient and
just spend your plans and your heat
because this also gives you terraform
rating so it also like helps build your
engine a little bit and sometimes it
makes a huge difference that you just
hook back these resources because it
could be the difference between going to
to generation I don't know 10 or 11 and
in the 11th generation you're going to
make so much points if you are the
greedy guy so so in this way you can
also prolong the game
it's really annoying but it can be
really effective that's brilliant I love
it so moving on to our eighth strategy
we also need to discuss standard
projects so are they worth the high cost
are they useful when should you be
thinking about these and would you
consider these primarily endgame moves
or when what's the best time to play
them
um first of all if you have standard
technology a lot of the standard
projects are just solid just by
themselves so so let's get that out of
the way but let's assume you don't have
standout projects or standard technology
I think it's called this card that makes
standard projects cheaper right but the
in the early game I mean
if you're playing with colonies then the
colony standard project is really good
it's really good in the early game if
you you can use like a Luna Pluto a
series or something that gives you a
decent amount of money income or
something like this so so I think the
the build a colony standard project is
really good it's good in the early game
and in the mid to late game it can also
be really strong to put it on on the
Miranda or the Titan the one with lotus
or something like this insulators
it can be really strong
but the the
um
the the power plant I believe it's
called
um that one is uh it's it's I mean if
you need it you need it it's uh
you don't really want to just take build
three power plants just so you can like
trade for instance but the
um but if you have like two energy
production then it's a really good play
to just buy the power plant to get the
last few energy production you need and
then you can then you can trade for
instance like if you're playing with
colonies but even with you if you're not
playing with colonies if you need
desperately need a stand-up project the
energy production then it's fine just
don't just don't just don't do it a lot
of times because generally the the way
the game works is that
cards are more efficient so standard
projects it's something you you do if
you have to but but you kind of hope
that you get a card that can do this for
you but maybe you don't have the right
card for the right situation so they can
fill in the gaps in your life I fill in
the gaps yeah for sure okay and then we
got the
if if you're playing Venus there is this
uh for 15 I I don't remember what it's
called but you can increase Venus One
Step there's also this asteroid where
you can increase the heat one step and
these two are terrible they're they're
really they're really bad you only use
these if you you really have a clear
purpose maybe you have like a venusian
animals you'll need to pump up the Venus
a little bit or if you're trying to lose
on purpose then you could use those yeah
I guess or maybe if you can get the the
bonus like if you have eight heat if
they're two steps to the water bonus on
the temperature scale and you have eight
heat then of course you you use eight
heat and then you also buy one asteroid
just so you can get that extra water
right because then you pay 14 to get a
water and the temperature then it's good
but the general rule you want to stay
away from those there's also like if
once again if you're really trying
trying to close the game if your
opponent just has the greedy engine and
heat is the last one to to to close then
it's also completely fine to maybe pay
for the last four heat just so you can
or play the asteroid standard project
four times just so you can close the
game in this case it could also be be
good
moving on to number nine how much of
this game is dependent on its style
placement or on the Tactical level of
the game and when you're placing City
and green tiles is there a particular
place or a certain way that you suggest
doing this when it comes to playing
tiles in general
um there's this pattern where you you
place your cities and then you place the
next city so that it can be like two
greeneries in between your cities right
so it's almost like this uh this pattern
with triangles if you know what I mean
yeah so that's the first thing but other
than that I think cities should be
placed in a way so they have a space for
a lot of greeneries around them and also
if they're already greeneries on on the
on the map then of course it's it can be
good to place it next to those
greeneries
um and then you want to place it in a
way so you can you can be next to one
water or something if you want but but
it's better to to be like in the middle
and then you have greeneries and all of
these greeneries they can touch the
water so you can get a lot of water
bonus adjacency by placing your
greeneries next to the water but your
Series has to be preferably
a little more in the middle so there can
be fiber or six greeneries around them
when the game is done very cool now what
about edges do you want to have any
tiles there or is there ever a time to
play around the edges of the I just
count how many greeneries can be around
them so if if there are no of the really
good spots left then you can only place
it on the edge well and just count how
many greeneries can be around it is
there some water close by some other
resources a card I can take into account
or something okay does it affect the the
Milestones or the awards especially like
on the Hillis and Elysium map there
there can be a lot of strategy where you
put your tiles in this case if you're
going for the uh what's it called desert
settler or the the estate dealer or
something like this but the placing it
on the edge of the map is okay if you
have nothing better but of course if
you're placing it on the edge of the map
is probably only a room for four
greeneries around it right it could be
better
so for strategy tip number 10 one Mantra
or philosophy I've heard for
terraforming Mars is that like the
Kildeer and wingspan forests win games
because they give you two points at the
end they raise your income they score
proximity bonuses and they essentially
pay for themselves really cheaply so do
you agree with this assessment I think
brand production is really good for sure
the way I like to do it the way I think
you should do it is in the first
generation and the on the opening hand
and stuff like this you can keep playing
production card in your hand but really
what you want before you start doing
this is you want to get your engine up
and running so so just spending the
first generation only playing brand
production that's usually not good
enough
but assume if we hit the early to mid
game I think plan production is really
good um
I don't agree that you just I think it
killed yet in wingspan is a lot better
than than just having greeneries in
terraform Mass like ecoline it's a it's
a fine Corporation but it's not Orwin
it's it's it is it's like only an
average corporation like uh it's more
important there's so many different
things you can do
um but The Greener is only at series is
only like a part of it
but uh once again we come back to the
number of players because
always it's good to have plant
production but the cities and plans if
you want to go all in on this then it's
better to do that in four or five player
games uh in in like in two player games
or three player games usually the greedy
guy especially the greedy guy with the
card strategy who just has a big engine
and a lot of cars it's usually way
better than placing cities and
greeneries but once again you have to
play the the cards you've been dealt
like if you've even in a two or three
player game if you've been dealt fastest
with immigrant City and you have some
playing production maybe it's something
like this then of course you go for it
but the generally speaking I I think
cities and greeneries are slightly
better in four or five clipping games
okay well despite my best efforts I
simply couldn't get the core strategies
into 10 points so we'll offer a bonus
value tip here and I'd like to ask you
if you reflect back on all the times
you've won this game where would you say
the majority of your points have come
from
um that's easy uh I enjoy greedy games
so it definitely definitely uh
cards because that's basically what the
Greely card strategy is right you just
you just have a lot of cards and then
you get a ton of points you get them
from jovians you get them from the
number of your car on the number of the
actual cards when you're done with the
game you get it and all the stuff you
have on top of your cards so especially
green tax energy that's that's a way you
can make like a ton of points in this
game
um so so me personally I think these
games are a lot more fun so so this is
uh what I would aim to do and I think if
you add a two or three player game I
think this is actually the best approach
to the game but if we're talking four to
five player games
um then it's it's it's just as good
maybe even better to just go for
terraforming or go for cities or
something like this cities can be okay
in two or three play games but I think
that this trade-off terraforming
strategy that that's just not gonna cut
it in two or three player games I don't
think yeah so so button for five player
games just just terraforming like crazy
try to close the game as soon as
possible that that's really good and
especially if I play games very nice now
out of curiosity do you have a favorite
card in the game pets has got to be up
there well it pets pets do you like pets
yeah pets pets is fun
um also Penguins uh I like me some
penguins nice uh it's a nice card
in terms of power level it's uh there's
some cards that you're just you just
know that these cards you're always
happy when you see them
um it could be like a advanced Alloys or
that's like so you got Olympus
conference you've got Martian University
and also you got this card
um
it costs 10 gives you two Mega credit
production and then you can draw a card
every time you play a card with 20 plus
cost I mean these three cards also
Stella these are always really good
that's fantastic
wonderful well if players want to go
into more depth to I understand you're
you're in the middle of releasing a
series of videos on terraforming Mars
and I think you explore a lot of these
issues we've talked about today am I
right
yes for sure I I I went all in I made
I'm a perfectionist in a bad way so when
I do something it's usually way too big
for for people's liking but there's like
yeah I made a lot of videos on my on my
Channel It's gotta be I don't know 20
hours of content just for a terraformal
strategy guide so it's uh it's
definitely in depth go big or go home so
we'll link to that in the description
and thanks so much for sharing all of
these ideas today but unless it was a
real pleasure speaking with you sure you
too
foreign